oh yeah yeah tightness in me that
tightness there it's actually really
good to see you in like not in person
but almost in person right you're the
first time we've exchanged emails but
this is the first time we're talking to
each other alive right yeah and it it is
amazing the world we live in
some people complain you know the modern
world globalization and all this kind of
stuff but I mean we have so many ways of
communicating with people all over the
world learn their languages I'm a great
fan of all this stuff I'm mad I study on
my iPad but first let me introduce you
to those who don't know all right who is
the founder of talk to me in Korean and
I kind of see you're not a one-man band
because you have people with you but
it's really such a variety of content
from beginner material talk to me in
Korean to the blogs
I bought the number of your books and
material from your website and I'll link
all the information about your website
on the description here but all right
okay let me start with this Korean if we
think of languages that people want to
learn in the world okay you've got the
traditional you know English your course
in Spanish and then to think of an
ancient language you think of Chinese
yeah even Japanese with sushi and anime
has had a bigger following I would think
so about Korean there's actually quite a
lot of interest in Korean and all that
you created it but you obviously you
cater to it how do you account for the
interest in Korea well I don't think
anybody really has a really good
explanation for the increasing demand
for learning Korean but it's just
happening that's for sure so as a native
Korean person I'm really thankful that
this is happening and also you know I
know still a lot of people are
interested in Japanese a lot of people
are interested in Chinese but especially
since I guess Korean people don't speak
a lot of English you have all the more
reasons to want to actually speak Korean
in Korea
just like you know maybe ten years ago
in Japan people didn't really speak
English so a lot of non-japanese people
started speaking Japanese right right so
that's for those people who move there
or live there but I think there are a
lot of people who never go to Korea to
learn Korean oh that's right I guess I
mean Korean dramas or Korean pop songs
are becoming more popular in some
countries so that's a factor I think and
also I believe this is my personal
theory a lot of Korean people who go
abroad to study or work right they they
try their best to avoid other Koreans
because that's the that's the reason
they're leaving the country you know in
the first place so right either because
they want to learn the language or just
because they want a different lifestyle
they just try to hang out with people
who are from other countries not like
Korea right and then naturally they
force people to try something you know
try something Korean I think they're
also spreading the culture in language
okay and what is your biggest market in
terms of which country which native
speakers of which language are the
biggest learners of Korean since we are
teaching in English and English is the
most widely spoken language in the world
I think you know in terms of the number
number of countries right English
speakers are the biggest audience and
it's interesting because the number one
country that actually listens to our
stuff remember and the number one
country that actually buys stuff can be
different yeah but I think digital
content consumption is really
commonplace in I guess in the u.s. in
Australia in Canada or in Europe so we
see a lot of sales from those countries
but overall we see a lot of countries
actually coming in to our site to learn
Korean especially in Asia right we see
you know english-speaking countries like
the Philippines or Singapore or Malaysia
huge interest from
country's right and the court de panne I
would imagine is a big yeah yeah but
since we teach mostly in English right
there are only a you know fraction of
Japanese people who actually comment
saying I am like in English I am from
Japan right I'm learning because I want
to learn English at the same time okay
now you speak Japanese right yes yes
okay so why wouldn't you also offer
Japanese language to do well material I
think in Korean or Japanese speakers
Korean for Japanese speakers are that's
a good idea
I mean I don't have any intention to
offer Japanese for international
learners because I believe there are
other people who are doing a better job
already but yeah maybe maybe in the
future but one thing that I want to do
before that is offer Japanese classes to
Korean people okay all right yeah I've
had my effective ways to learn Japanese
and I think Korean and Japanese are
really really similar right though I
think yeah we can probably do that and
so just so that people know you speak of
course yeah and in order of sort of
proficiency what are the languages well
in order of proficiency I'm just
checking whether there are comments here
because okay yeah in order of
proficiency reading English and then I
guess Japanese is the third okay and
then French is my fourth language and
Chinese and Spanish are kind of similar
I have to actually go to the country and
I can get by in how those languages by
myself and then when I read Italian I
surprisingly understand a lot more than
I'm so close to as you know and
Portuguese as well I Italian a
Portuguese similar level and yeah I'm
also very interested in Indonesian okay
so I'm learning learning those two right
yeah and sold so now we've talked so
what do you think now I find really
difficult
I know we're not just to say that the
language is difficult but I find it
difficult everything is difficult in its
own way right yeah Korean I have an
advantage because I speak Chinese and
Japanese so 50 percent of the vocabulary
is more or less identifiable although I
hear the obvious and so I haven't knew I
used my neighbor dictionary to find the
Chinese characters so I know exactly
what the word is that the Chinese are
added word in Korean yeah a lot of words
can have about fourteen different
meanings a lot of the shortened words
you know so if I use my online
dictionary I get six or seven words it's
hard to figure out you know cuz I rely
on online dictionaries in my learning
right but I think your point is that I
don't look at you're a little down there
I got a camera ma yes so but it's like
all these languages they seem difficult
at first and it's just it's a matter of
like getting the thing going and the
more you get going at first it was very
difficult for me and then as I you know
more of the pieces of the puzzle started
to show up then it became easier and
easier and I mean I mean as I told you
I'm working with some very difficult
stuff which is this Kim Jung Hwa's
literary podcast I mean he is it's very
interesting because he talks about
literature you know Japanese literature
Korean literature Russian literature
Frank literature there's there's lots of
stuff there and yeah a little difficult
for me but I love listening to it I love
listening to it even alright when I read
it with the help of the words that I've
looked up I understand you know pretty
well all of it but when I listen to it
I'm you know I'll understand it for a
while and I lose it I understand it I
lose it but I like it I draw the sounds
of the language I'm sure that if I went
to Korea and spent a few weeks there I
spoke Korean would improve but I'm sure
there's no question it's a challenge
it's a challenge and someone who didn't
have Chinese background I'm not sure
whether the Japanese house because the
word order is similar but the way in
which the endings work is different and
so on my brain tells me that it's a
Japanese construction when it's not a
Japanese construction
two Korean stars so there is a certain
element of confusion caused by Japanese
but it's certainly very enjoyable and
I'm I'm gonna get back to it although
I've been distracted by by Ukrainian now
my question is how much support do you
get from the Korean I don't know
Ministry of Education nor because all
these countries whether it be France
Britain they all like to promote their
language overseas so you're doing this
job yeah you get support from the Korean
government well to just give you the
bottom line nothing nothing from the
government well we did get some
acknowledgement last hour last December
we got we were recommended by the
government to receive this award in the
2013 Korea content a word so yeah all
the other recipients of the words were
like broadcasting stations and animation
characters or super popular TV dramas so
we were like really honored and this is
something that I can you know keep for
forever as a memory but other than that
other than the government say oh you
guys are doing a good job this is how we
will give you this prime minister
citation we didn't really get anything
they I know they are aware of us they
know they they know we exist and other
universities know about us but we're not
doing anything with them right now but
in the future I hope to do more stuff
with them do you get contact from
universities that teach Korean overseas
like in North America or Europe or Asia
well not often but I do give lectures to
Korean teachers who are teaching like
there's an assist there are a number of
associations of Korean teachers in North
America as far as I know and I sometimes
I regularly like every six months or so
give lectures to the teachers who are
coming to Korea for an orientation of
how to teach or how to train their
students so I know
some of them personally but we don't
like we're not working together on any
project right now but yeah I expect to
in the future oh you know I'm ready
question how did you learn to speak
English so well
yeah and that's that's the thing I I'm
so thankful because not many people have
done the same just by studying by
themselves during Korea but I was just
curious about you know many things that
I wanted to say in English so I would
look up things and then every chance I
got I would try to you know say what I
had practiced before maybe after five
hours of practicing writing something
completely new you know they might be
incorrect sentences but then I would
just use that sentence those sentences
in chatting room online or although
Internet chatting had only started like
17 years ago 18 years ago in Korea so
yeah I just looked for opportunities to
speak and in order to speak I had to
have previous you know preparations
right so that helped a lot
right yeah it is amazing the evolution
of language variant the kinds of
opportunities that are available to us
now yeah 15 years ago yeah I feel lucky
because I also was able to experience
language learning like before internet
mmm like the pre-internet learning you
actually had to record I wanted to I
wanted to improve my English
pronunciation so I had to actually buy a
cassette tape recorder and record button
and then you know the blank tapes that
you can record over over and so I you
know I feel fortunate to have
experienced that because these days
people will always you know think it's
too complicated or you know they have
all the tools they have that they need
in their hands with it you know many
people don't appreciate that so right
well yeah I know people ask someone ask
me on one of
my videos why is why is language running
so difficult and I mean my response was
made it depends on your expectations if
you if you think it's a matter of a
couple of weeks you know then it might
seem difficult but I think you and I
both enjoy the process
no as long as we enjoy the process we're
prepared to put in the time yeah I think
it's inherently difficult but it
certainly does take time yeah yeah yeah
and I think one thing that I really
enjoy is the Google or other search
engines image search mm-hmm so for
example if you read an article in a you
know in a language that you're learning
you can actually search for the related
images and then seeing those images help
the vocabulary words or the expression
stick a lot more in your brain so it's
like oh I've seen that I've been there
you know write that but I know a lot of
people do is or yeah there are so many
tools that people can use those tools
that work for them that's right yeah
yeah yeah no it's amazing to me what is
amazing it's the amount of rich content
that's available for each line you know
need just fine what but I think what you
do at the talk to me in Korean is is you
provide that sort of stepping stone
because you have to get from the very
very simple basic beginner stuff to
where you can actually listen to
something like Kim Young has podcast and
I know that Kim Young has parked podcast
is too difficult for me but I mean I
really appeal to yeah but there's
nothing that was empathy when I studied
Chinese they had excellent the books on
history that were intermediate so
anything bring up to be interested in
history I'm interested in history so
tell me now second question I'd like to
get into so before I do that so but you
have lived or you have not lived or
spent time in in the u.s. oh no not yet
yeah that's amazing
you've been very very well thank you
think yeah yeah I mean not only
pronunciation but it's just you can just
tell me that your use of words is
everything is extremely natural
like someone who has lived here for 20
years
English in Korea is huge
yes is there any interest for other
languages yes there is but this is a
challenge that a lot of people are
facing that maybe 20-30 years ago
English was probably the only language
that people actually thought of when
they you know talked about foreign
languages but then slowly the English
speaker market got saturated so people
started looking into other languages
such as Chinese because Chinese is the
you know language of the future as many
people say and favors
yeah and neighbors and Japanese Spanish
and but the thing is when those people
who studied or majored in those
languages actually went to look for jobs
they couldn't find anything satisfying
because for Chinese there are way too
many Chinese people who already speak
fluent Korean from maybe Perth you know
oh don't they are yeah yeah he and I
know so they they can't compete with
them and run their there generally their
wage is lower so it's extremely
difficult for Chinese major students to
get a job speaking Chinese or you know
without any other types of skill sets so
slowly I think the other languages are
kind of losing power in Korea so those
who kind of you know
hang in there those who become
well-connected enough with other people
and they get you know learn and other
things and get experience they can
actually work in the respective fields
but so right now I think it's kind of
turning back to English like everybody's
tried other languages but then in
realistic matters like I mean I'm
learning languages as a hobby like I I'm
passionate about it so nothing's gonna
stop me but then other people who wanted
to learn languages because of their jobs
they are like okay whatever you do
English is the strongest you know you
gotta
in English so yeah it's coming back and
then the overall English market is so
crazy it's saturated and also the
competition is really really high sure
yeah so it's a huge market now insofar
as how Koreans learn Koreans are
somewhat traditional in their approach
to education
yeah totally in their approach to
language learn and your approach I guess
would be considered unorthodox by Korean
standards
I think so you're not involved in
English learning you're are you also
involved in English learning or just in
Korean learn I'm also involved in
English learning I I started being about
two years ago because I got an
opportunity to host a radio show on
National Education Broadcasting System
so I've been doing I've been hosting
radio shows and a TV show on helping
people learn English so right yeah I'm
in both fields ow so how when you look
at the way English is taught because
you're saying basically language
learning in Korean is English so if you
look at how English is taught in Korea
what would you change
well that's a difficult question I
wouldn't change much about the
educational system but I would love to
change how much exposure people get to
actually interacting with people like
either you know exchanging emails or
messages or listening to people but or
speak speaking to people right now what
they're doing is they're dealing with
too many text books and they're dealing
with too many exam questions and those
who can point out like who can give
really effective pointers as to how to
score high on a TOEIC exam TOEFL exam
IELTS exam you know they make a lot of
money they become famous popular right
because they can help you get through
this little you know immediate challenge
right so I
totally changed the way how I wouldn't
change the way how English is taught but
how students are exposed to interactions
because right now everything is like the
knowledge is kind of piling up but all
under the surface no it's not coming out
to you know into the air now presumably
some Koreans they'll have discovered
that they can make you know fine
language partners on the internet that
they can general people speak to people
so something said that is happening
visually yes it is happening it is
encourage their kids to do this not
really
the teachers I mean it's becoming better
but the teachers were the average age of
teachers were in schools right now are
like 40-something gift is something and
they do that pretty old and they
themselves haven't really experienced
that and they cannot suggest something
that they don't know to their students
and thankfully I've been meeting younger
teachers who are in their 20s 30s early
30s and they're like my age or younger
than me so they are evolving their
mindset and yeah they're they're trying
new things I think like this the general
social atmosphere for language learning
is still a very I guess like
close-minded the people who have
discovered internet methods of learning
they can try new things for themselves
but they wouldn't do the same with their
other normal Korean friends because
that's embarrassing and they that makes
them blush and other Korean people will
kind of say speaking English or even
just you know making it official I am
learning English I I will speak to
anybody who can speak to me in English
you know making it public people are not
doing that enough so it'll take a while
I guess a few more years Korea is one of
the most connected societies in the
world I guess I think so
I mean it was it was way ahead of the
pack
the other countries have caught up but
the percentage of households that have
high-speed Internet is almost 100% with
some tremendous number right yeah yeah
yeah and and how widespread is the use
of tablets whether it be a Samsung or an
iPad or whatever um I think one in every
three / three people have won a
smartphone or a tablet or something of
that nature
I think smartphone almost like 95% of
everybody has a smartphone even
convenience stores like they sell like
semi smartphones for $30 or $20 and
tablets there they are quite prevalent
as well so people have access to those
tools do people use those for language
learning 20x10 not really not many
people but more and more people are
beginning to yeah interesting yeah I
mean I to me that those are tremendously
powerful tool tools for language
learning yeah I give a lot of lectures
to Korean people who are learning
languages and then um at the end of my
lectures I always like to give people
like real-life examples of how you can
how they can learn languages easily
using everything they have already right
and whenever I you know tell people like
about apps through which they can talk
to native speakers or get corrections or
image search or link people are like wow
those things existed I had no idea the
only thing they were doing with their
smartphones was maybe read newspaper
articles or maybe watch TV message with
friends take pictures right reading his
favorite articles in Korean or anything
Korean yeah yeah controversial issues in
Korean yeah yeah it's interesting I mean
everyone has a different approach to
language learning mine is somewhat
different from yours I'm not that
concerned about talking to people until
I have accumulated quite a bit of okay
then again I'm not learning you know I'm
very motivated as you say you know
you're motivated so I just keep going
I'm interested with what I'm studying it
I think that's what makes you different
from most Korean people will learn other
because they do a lot they go through a
lot of listening and reading right
they're not motivated so all the data
flow is just coming right through their
brains everywhere they're the key the
key to listening is that you have to be
interested when you listen to her that's
right
yeah and that's where I would rather
listen to something that I don't
understand very well like Kimmy on our
podcast then to listen to something
that's easy for me but of no interest so
you know you've got to be interested
right right now with with Ukrainian I
mean it's the the events there are so
dramatic every day than the opportunity
to listen to politicians and news
broadcasts and read about what's
happening there it's it's you're
basically learning about something else
by the language and the language just
kind of ends up you know you're left
with the language that's right it's
almost sort of incidental or I would say
self-conscious learning but not that not
deliberate it at any rate okay so you're
you expend a intend them to expand into
more English or you more English
instruction maybe maybe not I will
probably I want to launch other projects
for Korean people who want to learn
Japanese will want to learn Spanish or
French because there are not many books
out there for there are enough books for
Japanese you can you can learn Japanese
really really well in Korea because of
the similarities between the two
languages Chinese the same but Spanish
French maybe Ukrainian or Russian you're
already in training but yeah yeah there
are not many books out there and so I
would love to create create content with
other people who like native speakers
who were living in Korea right for the
Korean audience and I'm
or like for example French people who
are learning Korean they might
appreciate the same contents because you
know it's in Korean oh yeah no your
content you should be yeah absolutely
make it available to speakers of other
languages I think one last question
which is a personal interest to me I
have yet on Korean history that contains
characters like Han Jahn which is great
mmm on a search the internet for content
which is written in hanja and Hangul
can't find well you might want to look
into old newspapers because I remember
as a child thinking that believing that
newspapers were only for adults because
everything up until when I was 10 years
old which was in 1990 or 1991 or to
everything all the newspapers were
printed 70% in Hansa Chinese characters
and 30% in Korea only the particles like
or the native Korean endings were in
Korean everything else like the nouns
that can be written in Chinese
everything was written in Chinese so all
newspapers are all written like that and
they used to be written like Japanese -
like from top to bottom
yeah from online is the question anyway
yeah that's why I look it up and I think
I'll find it right now I'm out of
Ukrainian listener we could probably
talk for a long time yeah thank you for
doing this I will put some links to your
what should I put your blog
talk to me Korean yeah talk to me in
Korean and Cano song calm it has links
to everything okay yeah so well thank
you very much and I'm gonna now stop the
broadcast so thank you for having me and
it's great to talk to you
okay great to talk to you bye for now